ARUN NAGARAJAN: Hello
and welcome.
My name is Arun Nagarajan.
And in this video tutorial,
we'll talk about adding custom
menus to spreadsheet.
So menus are the top bar where
you're able to inject things,
like where you have file,
edit, and whatnot.
And in this tutorial, at the end
of it, you'll be able to
add your own custom
menus to that bar.
So let's get started.
So you will find the tutorial
under the Intermediate
Tutorials and Other
Tutorials section.
Just scroll down to the
section called User
Interfaces.
Click on Defining Spreadsheet
Menus.
And that'll be all the
code we'll need.
It actually says five minutes.
But it'll take a lot
less than that.
It's actually a very
straightforward process,
you'll see.
So in order to do this, the
first thing that you need to
do is have a spreadsheet
available.
So for this demo, I'll start
a new spreadsheet.
But you can also
use an existing
spreadsheet if you have one.
I'll just name this--
Custom menus.
And I need to open the Script
Editor in the context of the
spreadsheet.
So in other demos, you may
have seen us go to
script.google.com directly
and enter a code there.
But in this particular example,
it's very important
that the script is associated
with the spreadsheet.
And when you go to the Script
Editor for the first time or
if you have the welcome screen
still displayed, you may have
to close out of it to come to
the Script Editor here.
So as mentioned before, I'll
just copy and paste this code,
just a few lines here.
And I'll replace the stub
that we give you.
We'll save it.
We'll call it Custom menus.
And it's ready to go
at this point.
So you can see that the code
is actually pretty
straightforward.
We'll kind of break this
down in a second.
But let's just make sure that
we know what we're trying to
achieve here.
So here's the menu bar.
And the goal of this exercise,
at the end, is to be able to
have your own menu logic
associated in this bar.
So we're going to go in here.
And for this demo, we're
going to manually
run the onOpen function.
So it's going to run this.
And let's go ahead, and
I'll actually reload.
There it is.
And I'll reload this
page real quick.
And the onOpen should run.
So it gives a special meaning
to that function.
And there it is.
Now when I go ahead and
say, Say Hi, it's
going to run the function.
And all it's doing at this point
is showing a dialogue
saying, Hi.
As you can imagine, the
other one says, Hello.
Not very creative, but gets you
the setup necessary to add
your own custom menus.
Now, let's go take a look
at the code real quick.
And you saw that the onOpen
had special meaning.
And when I refresh the
spreadsheet, I didn't have to
run anything manually.
It just ran by itself after a
few seconds after it checked
for the existence
of the script.
And what it is is essentially a
set of objects in an array.
So this right here is
a JavaScript object.
It's a map.
It's got a name and a value.
The value is the important
part here.
This is the literal name of
the function without any
parameters.
So you don't have to put the
open-close parentheses there.
That's very important.
I've seen a few people
make that mistake.
And the capitalization
is also important--
functionName.
And that's really it.
And you can add any number
of menus you want.
In this example, like
I said, all we're
doing is show a dialogue.
But you could have your own
custom calculation, your other
business processes or workflows
that you can have in
JavaScript.
All could be injected in here.
As a simple addition to
something that you can do
that's beyond what's in the
tutorial, one of the things
that you can do actually-- and
you may see this in other
menus that we have--
is that we have this concept
of a separator in a few of
these tutorials, in a few of
these menus, I should say.
So as a little pro tip, I
can just inject null.
And now when I run this method,
I go in here, and
there's the separator between
the two menu options.
So that's a little nice thing
that you can do to really lay
out your menus the
way you want to.
And you can have multiple
menus as well.
So this ss.addMenu, you can have
multiple calls of this.
And it'll just stack left
to right in the
order you call it.
So I hope you found
this useful.
Take this tutorial and start
building your own complex
business processes and
interesting things that you
can do with your workflow,
with your spreadsheets.
Thank you.